hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John old M Humphrey we have a patreon
page
we are the first youtubers to ever have
one ever especially since ad pocalypse
occurred only once over there one of our
reward tiers whatever video you request
whether it be a reaction or discussion
let's face it they're most likely going
to be reactions because we have no
talking skills it is a reaction again
today from kid McKnight he is from
Australia this guy beating cancer that
sexy mofo as he should be I hope you get
out there now that you have successfully
been recovering go get laid my friend
spread the cream hey transition cream by
David Firth is his video request boy
this is the guy made salad fingers right
Oh
expect this to be disturbing did not
know that this will learn for a treat
let's check it out
[Music]
brain feeder like bring feeder records
[Music]
yeah mr. six years of splitting
stretching and firing distorted
particles of one another
a better we finally have a product cream
all right we're gonna love this facial
blemishes will be a thing of the past
[Laughter]
how about this botched nose job Wow is
it a challenge for Cree using our smart
awareness system cream detects the most
likely problem and attempt to solve it
by
in the molecular structure even quite
vague problems such as general ugliness
instant fixes for any kind of aging
chews and lacerations
oh the recently deceased the creature
isn't just limited to the human body
everything broken the pan and will be
fixed
broken is no longer an issue I love this
concept
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay like this suppose logical thing
that could be wrong is you're missing
rings ooh it's putting a lot of people
out of work with this cream man a man
who's gonna go to the hospital anymore
get your money
I want to see a black mirror episode uh
[Music]
yes the implicit formulation of dynamic
wave computational elements elapsed time
step size to be selected according to
accuracy requirements a damaged mind is
no longer a life obstacle if created
with a cream brain injection worries
doubts mental conditions and general
stupidity of all now curable she's in
the same needle for all them
let it soak a cream we'll probably pick
the activities due cream must be
controlling you guys yeah maybe it's a
hive mind
Guernica really teach your dog to be
that is your name I have yet to be
assigned a name well choose one Arnold
Billington Smythe it's a bit silly that
name though isn't it
I have to agree with you there Steve I
wasn't thinking straight
I don't feel very well daddy feeling
empty and bored now all your problems
can simply be creamed away Ferris cream
has taken the magic out of life well
bring it back
Lorraine my enthusiasm came back cream
yourself happy claim of the world
beautiful clean the everything fix it
because cream is the thick salt creep
America still be fixing and improving
itself
to be submerged in cream is to
continuously improve yourself in every
way possible
Super Soldier Serum
I'm gonna go bad no he exponentially
improved himself physically and mentally
to a zenith of absolute perfection
deadly evolving into a beam pure light
energy
the green now cream will reproduce those
are about six months from rolling out
completely
okay which is why the new version of
cream will have self duplicating
property screaming everywhere ah that's
suggestive is like a Darren Aronofsky
movie my train will solve extremist
wrinkler just getting real right
[Music]
those look like cut those graphic
specific like good PlayStation gruff
yeah oh wow it's making the perfect
sandwiches wish I had some of this cream
[Music]
green could bring it into warming and
suffering rendering money essentially
obsolete oh here we go yeah here we go
no no
[Music]
[Music]
what
know everything great has ample ah the
Queen causes AIDS and is made from dead
babies by pedophiles a shocking new
repair compliance there isn't terrifying
that was a huge explosion it's like a
zombie virus you wouldn't to placate a
life-threatening disease
you wouldn't duplicate a Kestrel so
don't duplicate food if you eat
duplicated food you're gay but what are
the public think but they angry about
cream cream three different types of the
hates sweet now my neighbor creamed
himself to become a god-like being
that's pure light energy just watching
me in the shower
[Music]
this is what would happen like a really
cool like high-five
[Music]
[Music]
he's waiting for it to get really
violent
[Music]
three types of eight on that plant life
Oh
the sandwich he's had all that food and
he's still still looking for new cream
the Wonder cream that fixes all spots
and blemishes simply massage into the
face and within a week your skin will be
clear and smooth like those Resident
Evil movie your brother corporation a
commercial facility yeah prove your life
[Music]
ah I'm wasting time dr. Drew Pinsky what
the hell man gives would you do that for
you know I never looked into like under
trying to understand salad fingers or
anything like that that was never my my
thing yeah I try to dissect like what do
this mean what is the deeper meanings to
this I feel like there's a lot you can
kind of draw from this though that I do
like because as this world I like it
because like a lot of things were saying
during the reaction it kind of reminds
me of an episode of Black Mirror just a
super absurd version of it and it's like
a fully realized world with the the big
stall product but there is no fix all
product yeah when you could design
anything you designed that's great in
this world eventually has a backlash as
a fall has repercussions so it kind of
has this like sci-fi commentary on we've
created a perfect thing to fix the world
but it's also going to destroy the world
yeah reminded me of the way in which
you'll hear like a scientific study come
out about like this thing's good for you
and then everyone just goes super
hardcore on it it doesn't bother to
check like how much you actually should
have to the point that it starts
becoming detrimental and yeah like this
is like a really extreme version of that
just with a bunch of extra backlash on
the creator yeah well I thought it was
very inventive in terms of everything
they're hopping like I was laughing
because it's it's funny but not in like
oh this is a straight-up comedy kind of
way in this one way you could take it
it's strange and in the commentary on
society was kind of making me laugh
because as they're inventing this
perfect thing to fix all you could just
feel but the evil things come and go
this is all this is all gonna go strange
and weird when we were watching the
backlash taking place and like the
negative side effects that could occur
from the crane oh yeah this dress is
exactly what would happen and that's why
I like because we all want the perfect
fix-it thing we all want the one thing
that could solve all our problems get
addicted we get addicted to it that's
impossible so when you attempt to do it
it's not going to turn out the way you
hope and it would just screw up the
entire world so I I really actually got
a major kick out of this video you
thought very clever it was very clever
yeah
I appreciate weird sketches like this
that don't have the traditional sketch
format I mean this does feel just like
its own little isolated strange little
film it just kind of goes until it's
done and it like he this this guy David
first like has a very specific voice I
feel like salad fingers is very
different from this but they always
leave me at the end being like I don't
know who else could have made this
somehow this was compelling even though
it's sort of amorphous and it's really
strange and kind of disconcerting but
also I enjoyed seeing the different kind
of animation that he's working with now
you know cuz that fingers very like
flash you know drawn animation and this
is like distorted people and photos and
stuff yeah it's like in developing
graphics of a PlayStation game and it
doesn't go like full-blown horror vibes
I mean really remember style things
remember southing it was like really
grossing me out I do appreciate that
this stuck more to its context and its
world and repercussions as opposed to
trying to shock you with disgusting
imagery I also appreciate the small
details like that one guy becomes you
know a being of pure light spy on chicks
gross but also like probably what people
yeah I doubt everybody's gonna truly fly
off into space and learn the secrets of
the universe because even though there
was like the scientific repercussions of
negative bodily side effects I could
occur from it it also explores like you
can't fix the consciousness of how
certain people will make choices and how
people will act upon things so it plays
into that which of course leads into way
more negative calling you have a
terrorist destroying the cream and
talking about how it's a disease and all
that your inventions only ever yours
until it reaches the hands of the people
and then it's whatever they make it in a
hashtag dude yeah they don't think about
food piracy - yeah you know like Noah
saying anybody's on food anymore because
you know people are bootlegging meals I
mean the only thing I'm surprised it
didn't go down was the path of people
maybe it was too obvious yeah to go down
but I made a comment about it people
will be out of jobs if you can fix
everything though you know like they're
fixing the cars mechanics are out of
jobs doctors who spent years going to
college and
probably have student loan debts me out
of a job now all those things that might
have been too predictable of a route to
go down although I wouldn't have been
opposed to if it did occur in here even
though if the animation might not be for
everyone I mean this video has like well
over three million views right now came
out last year names yeah I feel like you
could make kind of a full-length movie
version of this for the doctors the main
character yeah like the first half
everything's great and then the midpoint
something starts to go wrong then
everything collapses yeah just the world
goes to [ __ ] yeah just watch everything
crumble I feel like you could do a
full-length version of this that
amplifies its commentary and I've even
full support of that actually this is
that would be very cool to do get on
that Kickstarter David furthest to you
and make a movie thanks for making this
man salad finger cameo all right well
what videos by David Firth would you
call your personal fave leave it in the
comment boxes below and thank you to
kent McKnight for requesting this but
what a lot [ __ ] if it wasn't for you you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
hey click that notification Belko
subscribe buttons are broken and you can
check us on patreon where we do
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is music video coverage we love to have
you become a patron eject to die and to
caress and rusty spoons